[音楽]
ブードゥー君
みなさんこんにちは
竹下異例と申します
生まれも育ちも神戸でして両親や祖父も会社員
農業などの一次産業からは遠い場所で生活してきました
そんな私は今食べものがたりという団体を立ち上げ
大学に通いながら食の分野で起業準備中です
今日は私そんな私が大切にしているトピックの一つ
フード留守についてお話したいと思います
私がフードロスに問題意識を持ち始めたのは7年前
高校2年生の時に1年間いった体の留学がきっかけでした
そこではカナディアンファミリーの家でホームステイをしていました
当時まだ若い夫婦と
中学校2年生のホストシスターと小学校2年生のホストブラザー
晩御飯はだいたい肉をカチカチに約か
茹でたパスタに粉チーズをかけるだけか買ってきたピサか
そんな生活を送っていました
歩いのバーン
いつものようにホストシスターとご飯を食べていました
すると彼女はもう真花いっぱいだよーって言って
まだプレートにたくさんパスタが残っているのに
それをきちんの方に持って行きました
で私は何のキーもなしにその様子を見ていただけです
冷蔵庫に入れて次の日食べるんかなーってへ
それと彼女は
何の躊躇もなくそれをゴミ箱にしてました
幼い頃から米粒一粒残さずに食べるんだよって教わってきた私にとって
その光景はすごく衝撃的でした
きっとそれは彼女と私の食の違いから生まれたんだなっていうふうに思っています
そこから私は
世界の一方ではこんなにたくさん食べ物がせられているのに
でも世界のもう一方では食べられずに死んでいる人がいる
そんな世界全体の食のアンバランスに問題意識を持ち始めます
そこから世界人口が毎日おいしいで満たされた世界
そんな世界の実現を目指して活動を始めました
最初は関西学院大学総合政策学部に通います
それは国際協力という側面から飢餓問題にアプローチするためでした
しかし大学3年生になって私はもっと食に向き合わないといけないというふうに思い
神戸大学の農学部に編入します
そこで学んだのは
主に農業メインとして食を作る大変さ
そういうのを身を以て実感しました
大学4年女は休学して上京して急速冷凍機の販売商社のベンチャーでインターンシップ
をします
そこまで私はフードロスというと消費者が出しているものだと思ってたんです
けれどこの会社は冷凍技術を用いて流通段階だったり
生産段階なロスをなくすような取り組みをされていました
例えば北海道で1日何万とも取れるいわし
いわしっていうのはすごい傷つきやすくって鮮度の劣化が早いです
なので漁獲量の多くは油にされてしまっていました
しかし冷凍技術を導入することによって年がら年中
魚として消費者の方に届けられるようになりました
消費者段階だけじゃなくて仕組みによって
生産なんかや物流段階のロスをなくせるということに私は気づきます
私が体で感じた食べ物がせられているという現状
そのとき日本はそんなせてないだろうっていうふうに思ったんです
だって私たちはものを大切にするというか
もったいないっていう精神を持っているから
しかしそんな風に品のフードロスは
年間約640万とんです
世界の食料援助量の約2倍に値します
フード労組が出ている段階や原因はさまざまです
私が今取り組んでいるのは生産段階と消費段階です
少し具体的な話をしましょう
私は生産段階のキーワードは自然のぶれー
消費段階のキーワードは食への愛着だと思っています
ではまず生産段階の方からです
生産段階で発生してロスの原因は大きく2つです
労働力不足によって収穫しきれずにそのまま落ちてしまうものと
企画という枠組みによってそもそも流通に出せないもの
で私はこの時あるひとつの通りにぶつかりました
企画ってなんだよ
誰が作ったんで打っ
流通の効率化のために農産物の形が決められたりとか
消費者が土がついていない形の綺麗なものを求めたりとか
作ったのは生産者ではなく
食べる人や運ぶ人だったんです
ここまで企画企画という話をしてきましたが私はこの枠組みをなくしていきたいと思っ
ています
じゃあそのためにどうするか
それは贈答用などに使われるような形の美しいものと少し糖度が落ちてしまって傷が
ついているものを一緒に扱うということではなく
いわゆる b 級といわれるものに対して加工用という明確な用途を見つけてあげる
ことが必要なのではないかと思います
そこで私が始めたのが加工用クラムの流通事業
実になる味でした
例えばもも
a 級といわれるものは形がきれいで糖度が乗っていて重量をしっかりあるものです
いわゆる b 級といわれるものは例えば雨がたくさん降ってももに水分がたくさん
吸収されてしまって糖度が落ちてしまったもの
あるいはにが小さくて重量そのものが足りないようなものを
それらは生で食べるには奄美を感じにくく
美味しく食べることができません
しかしジャムなどに加工することによってもの食感や風味を生かしながら美味しく
食べることができます
果物の出来具合に対して適切な使用用途を見つけてあげること
それが規格外っていうものをなくすために必要なのではないかと思ったのです
農産物は自然からの贈り物です
そんな自然の振りを楽しめる人が増えたらいいなと思っています
例えば土がついているということはこれは悟ってくれたのかなとか
虫が食ってるって事は農薬少なめで作ってくれたのかなとか
そういった自然のブレを楽しめるような人が増えたら
企画という枠組みはどんどん広がっていくと思うのです
次に消費段階の話をしましょう
消費段階のロスいわゆる食べ残しだったり
家庭で冷蔵庫の中で眠ったまま伏せられてしまうような食材
それらが発生している原因は私は食への愛着への薄れから来ているのではないかと思っ
ています
モノを捨てるというのは食材に限った話だけではなく愛着があれば捨てないと思うん
です
例えば写真やアルバム
あれらはただの紙切れ一枚です
でもそのカミキリ1枚に数えられないほどの物語や愛が込められているから
私たちは捨てることができません
では皆さんがグラン食べているものに
愛を感じているでしょうか
多くの人の答えは no だと思います
コンビニやスーパーなど
工業製品化されていったり
あるいは作り手の距離がどんどん遠くなってきていたり
昔はそうではなかったです
例えば近くのおじいちゃんが作ってくれたきゅうりっていうのがわかるから
じゃあ全部残さず食べをおいしく食べようっていうふうに思うことができました
けれど今作っている人の顔も見えません思いも見えません
なので私たち食べる人は食べ物から愛を感じることが難しくなってきています
それによって何が起きるか
例えばおにぎり一つを捨てるってなったときに
こめの米粒の塊寄せているというよりどちらかというと100円玉をせているような
感覚に近いかもしれない
食べ物をしていることが簡単になってきています
だから私は消費者の方に食べ物を届けるときその食べ物の背景にある物語や農家の思い
を伝えることを大事にしています
これは何の員さんがつくったものでねこういうこだわりポイントがあってね
こういうふうに食べてくださいっ
すると食べものがたりのリピーターさんは今度は何9さんとこのブドウ売ってるって
聞いたんだよ
海に来たよって
少しつつ食品やのアイオー感じてくれているのではないかと思います
これらの問題はフードロスぬのみならず
我々のライフスタイルにも影響を与え始めています
食べ物に込められた愛用を感じにくくなっているから
消費者はどんどん食のことを考えなくなっています
私はそれを食への諦めだと思っています
誰かが興行的に作ってくれた食大何も考えずに選択していませんか
体をつくっている色でもしかしたら命に関わるかもしれないのに
自分が何を食べているか分からずに色を選択している人は
実は多いのかもしれません
私がフードロスや食産業という領域に向き合うとき
仕組みと意識の両側面からの解決を目指しています
仕組みが変わったとしても消費者の食の選択が変わらなければ何も意味がない
逆に消費者の食の選択が変わったとしても仕組みが変わっていなければ消費者は重要な
食の選択をすることができません
例えば曲がったキュウリを運ぶ物流の仕組みが整ったとします
でも消費者がイヤー曲がったキュウリはちょっと買わないよってなったとしたら
きっとスーパーに曲がったキュウリが並ぶことはないでしょ
反対に
消費者が曲がった距離でも買うよっ
ま償いすと同じ値段で買うよって言ったとしても
曲がったキュウリを運ぶ物流の仕組みが整っていなければ
それをまたスーパーに曲がったキュウリが並ぶことはありません
日本の棘そのダックスためにはまた1次産業を強くするためには
仕組みと意識の両側面からの解決が必要です
フードロスという問題を解決するのは非常にシンプルだと思うんです
作った食べ物を必要としている人すべてに届けることができると思うんです
私はそんな社会の実現を目指してこれからも頑張りますしみなさんも
市食の消費者として一緒にそんな社会を目指していけませんか
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]